all right well here in new york we can
all agree that the island in manhattan
is one of the most famous places
in the world but for decades a latino
community in the northern section called
washington heights
was largely unknown to outsiders it's a
place where spanish language
fills the streets and where i was born
and raised until i was about six
now the neighborhood is the center of
the cinematic universe
thanks to the movie in the heights based
on lin-manuel miranda's broadway musical
it was written by kiara alegria hudis
the half puerto rican half jewish philly
native lives in the neighborhood
that plays a central role in the story
almost as a character
when you're in the heights in the shadow
of the george washington bridge
if you close your eyes
the cacophony of spanish language and
music
might transport you to the islands
[Music]
amid the street vendors and the domino's
players
this latino community many with roots in
the dominican republic
serves as the backdrop for the hollywood
film celebrating community
resilience and a good time
[Applause]
so when you walk around the heights now
do you feel like you're in the movie do
you see the spots where you filmed
does it take you back well it's actually
a little bit the opposite it's like when
we were filming in the heights i felt
like i was hoping
[Music]
pulitzer prize-winning playwright kiara
alegria hudis wrote the broadway musical
the movie was her first screenplay and
she even got to direct some scenes
so what do you think is the magic of the
heights that has
captured audiences
you know i think it's just when you
ground and root your storytelling and
specificity
if you're not if you're not from that
world it's an invitation
to learn about that world to be in a new
environment if you're from that world
it's an invitation
to remember you know connect with those
details
for me it was an opportunity to
reconnect with the details of my
childhood this is where i lived as a
child
very young oh my gosh with my family my
mom my brother my sister
my aunt and her kids and our uncle at
one point also lived with us
like ten people i love it i love it you
depend on each other and you
share the same apartment because
everyone's trying to get by
you know when you come here it's like
you don't know the community so well so
you each
learn from each other's little tricks
and wisdom and and knowledge that you've
gotten throughout the day
tell me something i don't know
community as family is at the heart of
the film
where only together can the characters
meet their challenges
what are the people that live here what
was their response to filming into you
know
hollywood being here in the heights i
mean those are some of
really some of the best memories um
they would bring us whatever fritora
snack they had made that day
they would come and share a little bit
how did you guys nail the food well okay
here's the thing here's the thing
it's so like special interest for me
because growing up food was very central
i was like i want to see the pots i want
to see the spoons
i want to see the pike the hot sauce i
want to see you know
i want to see what kind of olives she's
putting the robot vieja because
it has to be the green olives with the
little red thing
[Music]
so you guys filmed part of the movie in
this park
yeah when i first saw in the heights on
broadway
i felt this incredible pride
because this is a community that's very
dominican very latino very
kind of insular in many ways and kind of
separate from the world of the rest of
new york city yes i felt seen
that's awesome
there's a sense of pride in sharing
those special spaces that have
tremendous amount of value
that carry a lot of wisdom and a lot of
history with them that the world outside
might not know about
in this film it's almost like washington
heights itself is a character
yeah to me the main character here is
the community and how they're going to
struggle together how they're going to
rise together
how they're going to hold hands but
they're going to feel the weight of
change pushing against those connections
and what they're going to do about it
my mom is dominican cuban my dad is from
chile mpr which means
you said you don't want this to be the
definitive work about the latinx
community you want this to
help push open the door further oh yes
how could it be it's another stepping
stone on the path and nothing more
to me in the heights is a success if
there's even more
latino stories filling in the spaces
i wasn't able to or i didn't get right
adding their own voice that's the
success
i love that song so it was so great to
be back in the heights it's so
vibrant and we really had a great
discussion with kiara but as you guys
probably know you know there was
criticism
that has emerged and it happened after
we interviewed her actually
and it was about the lack of darker
skinned afro-latinos and leading roles
in the film especially given the racial
makeup of washington heights
now in response lin-manuel miranda
issued a statement saying that he could
hear the hurt and frustration over
colorism
saying in part i'm trying to paint a
mosaic of this community and
we fell short i'm truly sorry
huda hudi's the screenwriter says that
she joins miranda
in his apology and his commitment to do
better now you know i'm an afro-latina
woman i am a black latina woman and i
i get it i understand the criticism
especially given the amount of black
latinos from
the caribbean that you know people who
also live in washington heights
but here's what i love about this
pushback it's creating conversation and
it's raising awareness
about the diversity in the latino
community we are not a monolith
everyone doesn't look like jlo as
fabulous as jlo
is yes and a lot of people don't realize
just how diverse we are and that we come
in all different colors so for that
i'm thankful well and and as you point
out what's important in this movie it
will
if it's success a success it will be
that there are other movies that tell
more stories
that's what you really want to see
happen here is that this is just the
first
and i don't think it's an if anymore i
think the movie's been a success yeah
and that's exactly what the screenwriter
said she says we want more movies like
this to fill in the holes we may have
left behind
or correct any of the mistakes that we
made so they're hoping that this is just
the beginning
that chance is coming i'm certain of it
if not i'll open a studio